I'd still find it funny everything it's
cute it still is mine but it's too small
so now you took it over with the helmet
too so cute okay happy weekend everyone
we are off for some fun surprises today
it's a getting to the end of summer and
kind of sad yeah go ahead on the Vespa
have to wear a sweater because it's a
little cool today so we're gonna take
you on our trip we will have fun
system Madonna I used to work there this
where we're going I'm kind of festival
it is buskerfest every year the top
buskers come to the Toronto and they
perform their basically street artists
so we're going to check it out do you
want a coffee baby starbucks at behind
one of the great things about Toronto is
every weekend there's something
happening in the city in the summer I
cannabis the summer yeah can be sad when
it's gone going to enjoy it while it
lasts I'm excited that there is a
booster juice it isn't a washroom so I
going to be answering your emails this
is what I do inches in the wash
so if you were in one of those things
what would you do
you can make stuff
No
we could do the moon you could tell
people jokes okay you know what in the
comments below I want you guys to tell
me tell Nina what you should do she was
it a shame is a busker on the street
trying to make some money in a show like
this what would you pay Nina to do
comment below I want to see it oh good
looking what I do we got to end it there
for sure
suicides a breakfast food the time of
the three three three bubbles 32 32
we're trying of Jackson groupers
free-range antibiotics healthy-ish
forget two burgers I'm tracking my
what steps we both got fitbit's let's
compare Nina's Fitbit says nine two six
four nine two six four k hold on
compared to mine press it again let's
see 9 1680 I got a set running outside
well cuz that'd be a lot more this
morning see my fear is my legs are
longer than what the same amount of this
thing but I take your steps so I feel
like that should be factored in this
this should have like normal steps and
aninha side steps then compared to see
the difference I hope I look small
doesn't mean that it's mother's death I
think our stem was a system
sounds like a challenge to me I want to
know if you guys have tried the damn
skippy and burger free-range beef peanut
butter and strawberry jam would you eat
that one no no I would try it I don't
like peanut that's true but on a burger
and beautified on a burger I would go
for that I actually read what that was I
probably tried not the greatest burger
ever are our mouth-watering let us down
let us down I am the pickles the road
alright well continue on that's the end
of our day hope you guys had a great
weekend thank you for joining us on ours
and
belief by